let's talk about your special career
suicide you are very very honest in it
about your depression your your struggle
with depression medication and and I
encourage people to watch it because
you're very honest it's but it's also
very funny it's and and you talk about
the side effects from the different
medications that you've taken a lot of
people don't open up about those kinds
of things yeah I felt like you know I I
had a lot of jokes that related to that
stuff and don't really feel I don't get
why it's so stigmatized when I'm not
supposed to talk about it it really it
did a lot of damage to me and I was
happy to talk about it did lead to some
uncomfortable moments like whenever when
you were doing it the one-man show yeah
uncomfortable moment I did a run in New
York for three months and I grew up in
New Jersey so a lot of people I knew
would come to the show and I didn't
always know when they were coming
there's a part where I talk about some
side effects of sexual side effects
specifically there was one of the other
drugs that yeah there was I took an
anti-psychotic it made me eat Jack you
late water I thought is that a question
or a
you know your your stay right there
you're safe there yeah yeah but I did
did it made me gonna do it now yeah but
yeah this was a situation it happened
ever heard of that side effect yeah I
hadn't either
it was it was pretty water came out of
here and then water came out of here man
cuz it was I was freaked out
yeah but I told this story on stage
every night in New York and then I would
always make a lot of eye contact with
the crowd very intimate show intimate
theater there's one time where I told
that story and I'm like wrapping up
talking about this like pretty brutal
situation and as I hit the punch line I
realize I was making direct eye contact
with my Aunt Karen oh my god yeah I
wouldn't want to talk about ejaculating
normally in front of my Aunt Karen you
know No yeah it was like deep I cough
yeah yeah deep eye contact
you